et c'est vous Oleg kopsaf bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes historiens et
géographe professeur de géopolitique
spécialiste de l'Europe de l'Est et du
monde article qui a l'américaine
University of Paris merci d'être avec
nous on vient de le voir à l'instant
beaucoup de questions autour notamment
de Wagner du patron de ce groupe
paramilitaire organique trigogine
notamment on se demande depuis ces
révélations à la presse américaine qui a
bien pu l'aider à mettre au point ce
plan et ça vous paraît ça vous paraît
logique vous y croyez vous à cette thèse
des généraux russes qui étaient dans le
coup
plus et notamment
solovkin chronique qui de toute évidence
se participait à une lutte des chefs à
l'intérieur du ministère de la guerre en
fait le ministère des de la défense de
la Fédération russe
ça c'est clair que de toute manière
prises n'a jamais attaqué Poutine
personnellement
cela dit il a été très violent envers
guerre et
qui est le commandant en chef et shoyu
qui est le ministre de la Défense et ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas un hasard et le
reportage combien de voir la très bien
souligné que ça va vite en fait
et redescendu comme numéro 2 sur le
front en Ukraine et avait peut-être des
comptes à régler avec les autres compte
à régler qui étaient les mêmes que ceux
de shoyu qui avait plus d'ambition je
crois que ce n'était ce coup
ça ne visait pas le Kremlin la
présidence ce n'était pas le calife qui
voulait devenir calife à la place du ce
n'est pas quelqu'un qui voulait devenir
calife à la place du calife c'est
simplement quelqu'un qui voulait devenir
vizir à la place du vizir plutôt
maintenant on a eu la leçon c'est que
quand on prépare un coup d'État il faut
être sûr qu'on va être soutenu et là
apparemment
il y a vous avez des forces politiques
qui n'ont pas bougé et peut-être je le
mets aux conditionnel celui qui était
dans le coup donc ce général ça va vite
qui qui avait peut-être promis
d'intervenir et puis qui sait
pardonnez-moi l'expression dégonfler à
la fin je me suis des scénarios et des
scénarios qu'on voit assez souvent dans
les dans les dans les coups d'État et
bien par exemple l'attentat contre
Hitler ou il y en a qui qui se sont
mouillés en mettant une bombe et en
complétant et puis les les principaux
chefs qui auraient prendre le pouvoir
ce sont désistés à la dernière minute on
a entendu hier un Vladimir Poutine et
s'exprimer
assez serein en tout cas c'est l'image
qui voulait montrer de lui il y avait
évidemment cette mise en scène son
discours consistait à montrer qu'il
contrôle aujourd'hui la situation qui
n'est le chef des armées ça c'est
important de le dire qu'il ne va pas
poursuivre en justice Wagner et qu'il a
presque envie de tourner la page comme
ça vous le croyez possible ça certains
disent aujourd'hui qu'il y a une purge
en cours au sein des généraux de l'armée
russe qui va y avoir quelques
changements
alors ça ça c'est très difficile à dire
quel changement il va falloir avoir la
liste
de des têtes qui vont tomber
attention parce que si il renvoie
shoeguerasimov ou les deux c'est au fond
donner raison à appeler gauche c'est de
dire c'est en fait pratiquement validé
toute l'attitude de pied gauche qu'on a
eu depuis des mois lorsqu'il faisait des
éclats des coups d'éclat dans les médias
et lorsqu'il a final finalement
marcher sur sur Moscou dans cette espèce
de tentative de remake de de la marge
des des chemises noires sur sur Rome
donc qui va quelles sont les têtes qui
vont tomber attention
Poutine Poutine devra faire très
attention
encore une fois à ne pas avoir l'air de
donner raison à appeler gauche
maintenant ce qui est quand même très
intéressant dans dans son discours c'est
de voir que qu'il accuse effectivement
des personnes
d'avoir tenté un coup d’état il parle de
crime il parle de de trahison mais en
même temps il termine son discours en
disant ah mais reconnaissons tout de
même que ces braves gens de de Wagner
sont quand même des patriotes il y a
beaucoup de leur commandant il ne cite
pas de noms qui qui ont qui se sont
trompés mais on peut s'entendre avec eux
bref moi j'interprète cela comment comme
une
comme une manière de dire on a toujours
on aura toujours besoin de pied gauche
et de ses wagneriens merci beaucoup au
lait comme chef
monsieur Prigogine qui reste
inhabituellement silencieux j'ajouterai
et toujours invisible il serait
actuellement en Biélorussie